[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSE UGIA: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to our session.
Today, we'll speak about how
to engage with your customers
with Google Pay beyond payments.
First of all, I'd
like to say, thank
you so much for being here.
We know it's not so easy at
this time of the day, right?
You're about to head back,
so we really appreciate that.
We'd like to say hi
as well to all of you
watching us from the Livestream.
My name is Jose, and I'm a
developer programs engineer
on the Google Pay team.
Together with me is--
MAILYS ROBIN: Hi everyone.
My name is Mailys and
I'm the product manager
for Google Pay Passes.
JOSE UGIA: So we
truly believe that we
have a valuable, insightful,
and actionable session today.
We'll go all the way
from the progress
that we have made
since last year,
we'll talk to you
about new features
that build on what
we offer already
through the Passes' API.
And finally, we'll look
back a bit into experience
to see what things can
we learn, so if you're
starting to integrate
the API now,
you can learn from
what we have found out
by developing the product, but
also what other partners have
seen, so you don't have
to go through that hassle.
And this session is
filled with demos.
So this is good for you, we
believe, for two reasons.
First one is you're going to
get to see how things look like,
really before you
actually implement them.
The second reason is,
that many chances for us,
there's many chances that
some things may go wrong,
so you probably have
some fun along the way.
So what do we mean when we
say the Google API for passes?
Well, we're speaking about
what's left in your wallet
once we have covered payments.
And we want to
help you, and help
your customers digitalize that.
We're speaking about boarding
passes, event tickets,
and loyalty cards.
Now why this is good?
Well first of all, you are
not only taking weight out
of your pockets and
space, but we also
benefit from the goodness
of technology, right?
So if you have many,
many, many cards,
then it's probably hard to just
keep them on in your wallet.
At the same time, we can
add some additional features
on top of it, like for
example, showing your customers
their loyalty cards
or their gift cards,
wherever they need
them, with things
like location-based
updates or information.
We'll talk about these
three categories today,
and we'll have new features
on each of those as well.
And this is just one example,
a subset of the partners
that have worked
with us recently,
and that I've integrated the
Google Pay API for passes.
We have success stories
for these partners.
As you can see, they're
in these five categories.
And currently, we'd like to tell
you more about three of them,
so you can probably get
inspiration from that.
So the first of
all is Lufthansa,
one of the world's
largest airlines,
which integrated the
Google Pay API for passes
in four different
channels through SMS,
email, mobile
application, and website.
And they just did
that in a few weeks.
So as you can read right in
there, the integration for them
was easy and quick.
That was one of the
highlights from it.
Which is something that
Ryanair shares as well.
Ryanair, as many of
you probably know,
is one of the
airlines that changed
the way we fly in Europe.
So for them, on top
of the how easy it is
and how quick it is
to integrate the API,
they highlighted and they
wanted to share with us
how open our team was to
extending the API to include
new functionality, and as
well as how flexible it
was to fit their use case.
Finally, Japan Airlines, with
their very particular and very
forward-looking vision
of smart airports,
in which the Google Pay
for passes and the ability
to digitalize those
passes, and make
them available to their
customers on their devices
was a crucial part of that.
Now, we'd like to give
you more specific numbers.
We have two use cases.
We have two case studies
from two of our partners,
and we would like to share
with you some success
metrics that they sought.
The first of them is Europcar,
one of the leading car rental
companies in Europe.
And as you can see, from
Europcar's head of loyalty
and brand's words, for
them it was a natural step
to think about
digitizing their passes.
With the uplift that they saw
in them in their mobile usage,
it made sense for them to
give their customers a chance
to have those passes
on their devices.
So with the help of Captain
Wallet, the company that
helped them build the
backbone of their integration,
they turned their privilege
loyalty card into digital.
They brought it to
the digital world,
they took the atoms into bits.
What they saw, as you can
see, were great results.
They got up to a 90%
digitization rate
on their customers,
on that loyalty card.
And amongst those customers,
70% were so satisfied
with that card that they
don't want to go back
to the physical card.
MAILYS ROBIN: So the
second case study
is from Multikino, which is
one of the largest cinema
chains in Poland.
And Multikino implemented
the full Google Pay solution
from letting their
users pay online
for cinema tickets to saving
them in the Google Pay app.
And what they've
noticed is for users
that have their tickets
saved in Google Pay
compared to users
that are using paper,
the check-in into the cinema
was four seconds faster,
which had a huge impact
on their business
because it would just
remove a lot of queues
and waiting time for users.
Also, the month-to-month growth
of people saving those passes
were 2X after launch, showing
that users really liked it.
And generally
speaking, they found
that it's a great way to
communicate with the user
through the API with updates
and just notifications.
So we've covered testimonies
from partners on the loyalty
side, cinematic, and flights.
But now we cannot wait
to show you what is new,
which is probably why
you came here today.
So, first, we want to make
passes accessible easily
to user.
They should be
informational and it
should be just available
there in one click
as soon as a user needs it.
So to go through the
first set of features
that we have for you
today, we actually
are going to use Jose's
personal experience.
So, Jose, do you want to
tell us a little bit more
about yourself?
JOSE UGIA: Yeah,
I have to confess
that I have a bit of a bad
reputation with my friends,
because I've missed some
flights in the past.
I keep on telling them that
it's not really my fault,
because, you know, some
things just can go wrong.
They're out of my control, but
I guess it's not really helping.
You know how it
really works, right?
You have to book a
ticket, then at some point
you would check in,
which is different
for different airlines.
And it doesn't get any better
once you get into the airport.
You have the stress
of the check in,
and it gets even worse if
there are things changing,
like your boarding time or
your boarding gate changes.
So I actually know that
we have some features that
are going to help me with that.
So why don't we just share
them with our audience?
MAILYS ROBIN:
Yeah, so how can we
help people like Jose and
just generally people,
to make the travel experience
faster and nicer and less
stressful?
So we really believe that
using the Google ecosystem
can really help us building
strong user experience.
So to remove the
stress and the process,
and so users can really focus
on what matters to them.
So this first feature
was announced at CES
earlier this year, and
is the flight check
in for the Google Assistant.
The way it works is, as a user,
when I'm ready to check in,
I would get a notification.
That notification would bring
me to the user assistant.
In a few clicks, I can
complete the check in,
it's really simple.
And then at the end of
it, I get a boarding
pass that I can access later.
The reason why we are
talking about this feature
also at this Google
Pay Pass session
is because the API to
get the boarding pass
is reusing the Google Pay API.
Meaning that, as a developer,
if you already implemented
the passes API to
let your users save
your boarding pass from
your website or your app,
this is just incremental work.
So you just have to
implement the check in part
with the Assistant, and
you will get both features.
So this is launching
right now with United,
and we also have
Vueling and Lufthansa
integrating and launching soon.
But I'll just say
it, like it's simple,
but how about we
just see it for real?
JOSE UGIA: Actually, this
is really convenient,
because my flight is just
taking off in a couple of days.
So if you don't
mind, I'm just going
to go ahead and check
in to my flight.
So I'm going to
go to my Pixel 3,
and I'm going to
open the Assistant.
I'm gonna ask it
to show my flights.
Show my flights.
So as you can see,
once this loads,
I'll see my card for my
upcoming flight, right?
And if you look a bit
below in one of the chips,
we have the option to
check in right in there.
So I'm just going to take that.
Great, so I'm just
going to be asked
a few questions in this really
nice conversational style
that you already know
about our system.
I'm gonna say, yes
I'm ready to check in.
Then, I'm going to
be asked, again,
I'm gonna go through the
process of check in, which
may vary per airline.
I usually travel light,
so I have no bags with me,
it makes it easier.
I really hate to
wait at the belt
when I'm in the
destination airport.
Now, I think I don't have
anything that is forbidden,
so it should be good to
go, I'm confirming here.
And once this responds,
then what you will see
is that the process is now done.
But actually, my
favorite part of this
is that, I'm not only
already checked in,
so I can forget about that
and enjoy the rest of I/O,
even though it's not too much.
But I can also show my
boarding pass, right?
So you can see how close
to me is this right now.
Actually, I'm going to
show my flights again.
Show my flights.
Or maybe, if we get
proper connectivity.
Show my flights.
Let's see if that
worked, there you go.
So you see, I have my boarding
pass already in there.
So the Google Pay
application is opening
and it's showing
my pass right away.
You saw that it took
me maybe two attempts,
but it was just one
tap away, right?
So when I'm in the airport,
this really helps me save time.
So with that, let's
head back to the slides.
MAILYS ROBIN: So this is
great before your flight,
but how about once
you're at the airport?
And the airport is usually
a really stressful moment,
because I have to think about
my luggage, maybe my kids,
I have to go through
a lot of checks,
so I don't want to think
about just accessing
my papers or my boarding pass.
It has to be available,
just there when I need it.
So this is why we launched
earlier this year,
high priority notifications.
So those are persistent
notifications
that are on your screen three
hours before your flight takes
off, and that can be used to go
back and forth to your boarding
pass in one click.
So when I'm there, just one
click, I go to my notification,
to my boarding pass,
and then I can come back
and it's already there for me.
This doesn't come at any
extra implementation cost,
it's just there with the API.
And if you also
have event tickets,
we have the same
notification for events.
And this will be
dismissed automatically
when my flight takes off,
also you can manually
dismiss it as a user.
The second thing that
is really stressful
is last minute changes.
So I'm at the airport
and my gate changes,
or my flight is
delayed, I don't want
to have to look at the
screen all the time to see
if something changed.
So we also have a status
notification updates.
So if something is delayed
or if my gate changes,
the airline can send a
push update to the API,
and we send the notification
to all the users
that have that boarding pass.
Meaning that for me, as a
user, just all the updates
are just there in my phone.
No need to check anything else.
So to recap, boarding pass
available one click away,
or even one slide away,
because the barcode is also
inline in the notifications,
so you can even use that
to board your plane
or access your event.
JOSE UGIA: That's great
for airline passengers,
for airlines as well, but
we use different forms
of transportation to
move around, right?
It's not like we move all
the time using planes.
We're really happy to tell
you about that, recently,
we opened up part of our APIs
to support transit tickets
as well.
And it works really similar
to what you have seen now
for boarding passes.
Right, so you are able to,
first of all digitalize tickets,
but also you can associate
barcodes, like QR codes,
to that ticket.
And on top of that, as
you just saw for flights,
we're able to
create notifications
based on updates that happen in
real time coming from your end.
Now similar to the
boarding passes,
once again, we'll have a high
priority notification showing
up, this time, one hour
before my trip begins.
So I have my ticket
right there to access it
whenever I need it.
Eurostar has been
the first partner
to launch with us using the
Google Pay API for passes,
but LNER and Russian
Railways will
be coming soon later this year.
Here you can see how
it actually looks like.
This is a transit
ticket from Eurostar.
So if we are actually going
to or from London, Paris,
or Brussels, you can just
go ahead and try it out
for yourself right now.
All right, I see,
yeah, I understand
that we are a bit far
away from those cities.
So I guess you
have no motivation
to go and book a train
for those places,
being 6,000 kilometers away.
Well, fair enough, we
have a demo ready for you.
Mailys is going
to show you how it
would look like if you did it.
MAILYS ROBIN: So going
to the Pixel phone.
So I used to live, a
year ago, in London,
and in case you haven't
noticed before, I'm French.
So going back to Paris was
something I would do often
to see my family.
And Eurostar is just a
convenient way to do that.
So I'm just going to
book my next trip.
So opening the Eurostar app,
I'm gonna book my next journey.
I think in a week's
time sounds good,
so let's just pick the trains.
So I have a nice promo here, so
let's just do standard premier
and then, yeah,
return 8-13 is good.
So I booked my trains,
now going to the checkout.
So on the checkout
page, as you can see,
we have the Google Pay option
to purchase the tickets, which
is great, because I don't
have to input my credit card
details here, so that's faster,
and also I know it's secured.
So I'm just going to go ahead
and buy with Google Pay.
So here I can also
change my card details
if I want, in this case, I will
just continue with this one.
And then confirming the booking.
And my payment was
accepted, I have my ticket.
So I can now download
my ticket, so here I
see a button on Google
Pay, save to phone,
where I can save my ticket.
Now this trip is in a week.
So at this point of
time, I might not
have time to save
my ticket, or I
might want to save them later.
So let's just
ignore that for now.
Now going fast forward
a week, now this
is really close to my trip.
So I might want to
save my ticket as well.
So I might not want
to go back to the app,
or I forgot about it.
But Eurostar also sent me
an email for my reservation.
So I'm just going to open
this so I can see my tickets.
And I also have the Save
button here as well,
which is great, because I
want to save them right now.
So I'm just going to
save the first one.
Oops.
Just going back to the
email and saving it.
So I get a confirmation screen
to save my ticket, so saving,
and then I can see my
ticket in the Google Pay app
where I can access it.
And was mentioned
earlier, I will also
get a notification an hour
before my train starts,
so I will be able to access
my pass from there as well.
So going back to the slides.
So this is for
static barcodes, it's
something that might
not update all the time,
but we are also
working on announcing
this API to support dynamic
visuals and dynamic barcode
or QR codes.
What a dynamic barcode
is, is a barcode
that will updates every
couple of seconds,
even if the device is offline.
And what that really
means is more security,
because somehow if
someone was able to take
a picture of my pass,
or just replicate it,
this pass would only be valid
for the next couple of seconds.
Because after that,
this pass will also
update the barcode again,
and it's much harder
to commit fraud.
So we are working
on this right now,
it will be available
before the end of the year.
And we are working with
Token Transit, which
is a company that provides
tickets and other services
to transit agencies to
integrate this wisdom.
And the same as
for boarding pass,
we really think that
utilizing the Google ecosystem
can help us building
great user experience.
And when we're
talking about transit,
the first Google App
that I can think about
is Maps, because this is where
I'm going to start my journey.
So when I want to
go somewhere, I'm
just going to open Maps and
search for the best itinerary
to go somewhere.
So we are adding a feature
to purchase tickets and save
the tickets in
Google Pay from Maps.
So from a user perspective, I
can just do my whole journey,
from searching for my itinerary,
to redeeming the tickets
from Google Pay at the
transit agencies in one go.
So this is first, this
actually has launched already
in Melbourne, Australia.
With NTT Data and Public
Transport Victoria
for the myki card.
And we are just going to
show you how it works.
JOSE UGIA: Let's do
a little exercise,
an exercise of imagination.
So just come with
me, let's teleport
our minds and our bodies
all the way into Australia.
We're going to Melbourne,
imagine, like really all of us,
it's a bunch of people.
So we're there, we have
been spending the day
just checking out some places.
And now it's a bit late in the
evening, we're a bit tired,
we're hungry, so we want
to go to a specific place
that we were recommended, right?
So what would we typically do
when we are in this situation?
We go ahead and we open
Google Maps, right?
You probably are doing,
already today, dozens of times.
So the place that we
are going to go to
is near to the town hall.
So why don't we go ahead
and select that place.
We are right now in the zoo,
so this is our origin point.
Now, as you can
see, you probably
have seen this
screen many times.
We'll get a few options,
we'll go for the first one,
it takes us 29
minutes to get there.
Let's go ahead and select it.
And now it produces something
new, right at the top.
I have the option to add
or use my myki card, right?
Right where I need it,
right on the default
view of the planning
of my route.
Since I don't have a card, I'm
going to go ahead and create it
right now as we speak.
So we're just going to be
there for a few more seconds.
So why don't we go ahead
and get the prepaid card.
There you go, I'm going
to go for the full fare.
And now, on my payment method,
I select my payment option.
I'm going to top up
10 Australian dollars,
I think that's going to be
enough for all of us probably.
So I'm going to continue,
and as I purchase,
then I'm going to
see that reflected.
Now as we get back
to Google Maps,
we're going to
see that reflected
next to the route where
I just saw my myki card
for the first time.
Now you saw that this was
the first time I did that.
So it was a process to buy
it, it was still really quick,
but now once I already
have it, and if I go back
to Google Maps, this is
going to show up in there
and it's going to show
my current balance.
So all I have to do, is just
get close to an appliance,
tap with my phone, and
then off I go, right?
So this felt probably
pretty straightforward,
but what I would like
us to do, is just
take a step back and
compare that to the way
we have been doing
things so far.
So after finding the route
that we want to go through,
we normally had to get out
of our application, right,
and find another application
to buy the ticket or a website.
Or even worse, we had to
look in the physical space
to see if there was some
appliances to buy a ticket.
So you can see how, with
integrations like this,
the life of your customers,
but also your life's
going to be much, much simpler.
So if we could, go back
to the slides, please.
We'd like to tell
you about, so this
was like for Melbourne
in Australia,
but this is just the beginning.
We're building a similar
integration in Japan
with Suica and JR East.
Suica is an e-money
prepaid card that
allows you to pay on
buses, on the subway,
in trains, and in shops.
So if you live in Japan,
or you go there often,
stay tuned because we'll have
more updates later this year.
Now we have spoken about
transit and about airlines,
but what's there
for all of you who
wanna engage with your
customers a bit more
to create longer lasting
relationships, for example,
a loyalty program, right?
We think you'll be really
happy to hear that we're just
making your life easier
in terms of accessibility
and discoverability of
those loyalty cards.
Because I'm sure it
has happened to you
that, maybe you got new sign
ups into your loyalty program,
but then your customers may
have transacted once or twice,
and maybe they
didn't do it anymore.
It can be that they
weren't interested anymore,
but it's also likely that
they simply forgot about it.
Or the email you send them is
just below a pile of dozens
of emails, so they cannot
find it anymore, right?
So we added the ability
to import loyalty cards
automatically from Gmail.
So all your customers will have
to do is simply open the Google
Pay app, accept
the consent screen,
and then they will
get all the loyalty
cards automatically imported.
You'll probably be happier to
hear that the integration, what
it takes from your end, is
just really little, almost
effortless.
All you need to do is add
Markup to your emails,
so that our parser can
just find those cards
and add them to your
customer's Google account.
We promised that the
theme of this session
was going to be
showing things live,
so how about we stop saying
and then we start doing.
So Mailys, you want to
show us how this works?
MAILYS ROBIN: Yes, so
going to the Pixel.
So here I have my Google Pay
app and there are a few ways
to trigger this.
So if you have object
in Gmail already,
you should see a consent
screen, but you can also
trigger this feature
manually for later.
So in the settings,
you can go to General
and you'll find the
Gmail import settings.
So this is the consent
screen, so I'm just
going to connect my
Google Pay to Gmail.
It's connecting, and
it found three passes.
So United, so that's
the one that I
marked with a little nail.
So we have a Kohl's rewards,
National Car Rental,
and United Airlines.
So you can see that now I
can see my number for United,
it's pretty easy.
I can even see the email that
we used to trigger that card,
in case I want more information.
So this is working right
now only for loyalty,
but we will be working
on extending it
to other types of passes.
And also, as was
mentioned, as a merchant,
if you want to make sure
that your detail gets passed
into Google Pay, it's
just a few lines of Gmail
to add to your
email, and we'll have
this ready in our
documentation, which is public.
So it's something you
can do really easily.
So going back to the slides.
And this is really useful
for your existing users,
but how about new users?
So an option that we
have in our passes
documentation for loyalty,
is the option to add,
sorry it's going ahead, a sign
up option for a new account.
So as a developer, you
can enable that option,
and then in Google Pay, when
users manually add passes,
if they look for your
brand or your store,
they will see that
option to sign up.
So the way it works is
we show a screen that
is configurable by you, so you
can tell us which user details
you need to create a loyalty.
So first name, last
name, maybe the zip code,
or an email address, then
clicking on the button,
will bring you to your
website where you can
create that loyalty program.
And then you will send it
back to Google Pay, where
the user can see their
newly created loyalty.
So from there, you can
access to the users
so you can send them updates
on the loyalty points.
And it's even something
that you can, for example,
offer in store.
Where, if you ask a user to
sign up for something in store,
they can just have a new program
in a few clicks, and then
they already have their
loyalty card ready.
And they can scan it, and
just start collecting points
and everything.
And last but not least,
we heard you last year.
So this is all great, but
what if my users don't have
the Google Pay app installed.
Well good news, we
are working on this.
So starting with a boarding
pass, even tickets,
and extending later to
other types of passes,
we are working on making
those passes available
even if the user doesn't
have the Google Pay app.
And the first iteration of
that will be through web views.
So if the user doesn't
have Google Pay,
we'll still render a web
view of their boarding pass.
So an example of entry point,
for example, is the Assistant.
And this feature will launch in
a month or two, so really soon.
And the way it works is,
once I save my boarding pass,
I can ask the Assistant,
Hey, Google, show me
my boarding pass.
And then I have a chip there
to see my boarding pass.
If I click on the chip, if
Google Pay is installed,
it will, of course,
open Google Pay.
But if it's not installed,
we will open a web view.
So how about we also demo it?
JOSE UGIA: Yeah, and
also in the past,
I've gotten this wrong a
few times, as you know.
And so I just
checked in, but, hey,
I would rather double
check and make sure
that my boarding pass is there.
I don't want to find that
out when I'm at the airport.
So let's go to my
iPhone this time.
I'm going to show you
how to do this now
from the Assistant on my iPhone.
So I'm going to
open the Assistant.
Show my flights.
So I'm just going to
retrieve the same flight
that I checked in
for a second ago,
and as you can see this
time, in the chips below,
I don't see the check
in option anymore.
That's good news, I'm
checked in already,
but I can see the
boarding pass, right?
So I can open right from there.
And there you go, it will load
directly on this web view,
right?
So similar experience,
now on my iOS device.
So let's go back to the slides.
And just take a
step back and recap,
we have talked about
a number of features.
We'd like to just summarize
them up looking at them from two
different points of view.
First of all, what do
you get we integrate
the Google API for passes?
Well first of all, is you will
digitalize your pass, that
is, your customers will
be able to have access
from their devices to their
boarding passes, loyalty
cards, and tickets.
With that one click
access that you
just saw a second ago on
the Assistant on my iPhone.
You also get the ability
to update your passes.
That is, that will
generate notifications
as well that will inform
your users what to do best,
how to react, right?
Especially when they're
in stressful situations.
Finally, if you remember, we had
the high priority notifications
that will give me
access to my pass
right away from a notification
whenever I need it.
From a different perspective
now, let's look at it
from what things can we add
to the API, what functionality
can we add to our
customers, as well, just
with very minimal effort.
Well first one is, as you saw,
just by adding email markup
to your emails,
then Gmail will be
able to import automatically
those passes for your customers
into the Google Pay app.
Second, you can allow
users to sign up directly
from the Google Pay app,
so they don't have to leave
that application, right?
Which you know will
cause more friction.
Finally, on integrating
cross product
within other parts of the
platform in Google or other
products, you just saw how
we integrated the myki card
on Google Maps right
where you need it.
Or how you can check in with
the Assistant for your flights.
So this is what we had
in terms of new features.
We also talked about the
momentum before, right?
In the last section
of this talk,
we'd like to talk about
some best practices.
Tips and tricks that we have
learned through our experience
developing the product and
talking to our partners,
so that you don't have to go
through that hassle again.
We have two tips on the button.
The button is that gateway
into digitalizing your pass
that we have seen already
a few times, right?
We strongly recommend you
to build a button that
goes directly to the pass.
No intermediate screens, if
you can avoid extra latency,
do that too, because that
will generate drop offs
and reduce your conversions.
Second, you can put many passes
behind one single button.
So for those use cases,
like multi-leg flights,
or bookings with many
tickets, like for example,
when you go with your
family or friends
to the cinema or the theater.
You can just put one
button behind that
and that will take care of
generating all those passes.
Now from a UI UX
perspective, right, there
are two more tips that we'd
like to share with you.
First is that, you
don't have to worry
about the designing
of the button,
because we help you do that.
We have JavaScript libraries
for the web, and graphic assets
for your mobile applications
that you can just
take them, import them,
and just have them,
based on how your
application looks
like, you can choose between
the light and the dark themes,
right?
The second is, make sure
you choose the context
that it's right for
your application.
What we mean with that is,
that you want your users
to know that when
they click the button
they're going to digitalize the
pass and you're showing on top.
This can be a matter of
colors, backgrounds, frames,
and shapes, but also
about bits of information
that you can see
in this example.
MAILYS ROBIN: And
then, digital passes,
so the power of digital passes
is that they are digital.
So they can be updated
in real time at any time.
So compared to a paper, if
a user just gets new points,
you can reflect it
right away on the pass.
If they got a new seat upgrade
in their plane or transit,
that's something you can show.
If they got a new airline
tier, you can change the color,
you can make it look
different, so the user
feels like they
achieved something.
And there's no need
to reprint any paper
or reissue any plastic
cards, it's just there.
And also, I will
show you earlier,
any importance of dates will
also trigger notification.
So that's why it's really
important that any updates
that you have, you can
just send them to the API
and we'll update the
object for the user.
And finally, use
all the channels.
So have you seen it
in the Eurostar demo,
or with Lufthansa who's using
a lot of saving channel, it's
important that the user
find the button where
they need to find it.
And that place
could be different
depending on where
they are in the flow,
for like the purchase
and the save.
So it could be in the
website, could be in your app,
in the email, or an SMS.
So it's important that they
can find the button anywhere,
so once they're ready to
save it, they can find it.
So you increase your CTA.
So this is an example, also,
for even tickets, where
you can put the
button in the tickets,
but also after the
purchase confirmation.
JOSE UGIA: Finally,
to wrap it up,
we'd like to leave you
with three call to actions.
We said before
that we wanted this
to be an actionable session.
So based on maybe how
you feel right now,
we hope we have three
really good links for you.
We hope we are on target.
First of all, if what
you heard makes sense,
this sounds good to you,
you want to find out more,
you want to check out
documentation, reference
API, see more tips and tricks
maybe, just use the first link.
Go to g.co/pay/passes to see
more of what we have told you
already.
If, otherwise,
you're ready to go,
maybe you're good to implement
the API and digitalize some
tickets, passes,
and loyalty cards,
well then use the second
one g.co/pay/passes-sign-up
to create a merchant account
and start calling the APIs right
away.
Third, if you would like to hear
more about us, more use cases,
maybe more tips and tricks,
maybe more information about
our partners, just use the
third link, g.co/pay/stay-tuned.
And speaking of
staying tuned, we
would like to let you
know more about an event
that we'll be running later this
year in September in London.
Which is going to be
exclusively about Google Pay,
it's called the Google
Pay Developers Live.
So if you want to see more
use cases, case studies,
want to see more best
practices, you want to hear from
our partners directly, make
sure you check out that link
in there and we'll get
back in touch with you,
g.co/pay/live2019.
Finally, we hope we
added value to you today.
If you have questions or issues,
we'd love to hear from you.
We're just across the
boardwalk, we're in Dome A
together with the web team.
We have a team of
people there who
will be willing to really hear
your stories, your issues,
and see if they can help you.
For those of you joining
us from the Livestream,
or for all of those people from
the future who are watching us
from YouTube, use
that link in there
to get started with the
Google Pay API for passes
and hear more from us.
Finally, we really hope
that was useful to you.
We hope we gave
you good examples
of what you can
do with these APIs
and how you can apply
that to your businesses
to make the life of your
customers simpler and easier.
We'd like to thank you
so much for spending
this 40 minutes of
your life with us,
and we hope to see you soon.
MAILYS ROBIN:
Thank you everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]